laughs I I wonder rick is um oh
you see that's Tony calling
hello hey Wendy it's me I'm in flight
right now when are you going to get here
to be precise
I don't know I'm cleaning up a minor
situation at the moment I'm gonna get
there as soon as I can oh listen do me a
favor stole everybody buy me a few more
minutes okay just throw a party
everybody loves a party gotta run bye
sorry everyone I thought he'd be here by
now but
but the iron Mets are here they've been
a fixture of every stark Expo ever since
Tony took over Stark Industries so let's
take a moment and invite them to the
stage to entertain you now ladies and
gentlemen the ire Nets
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's give it up with the honor an axe
[Music]
you made it I told you I came here as
soon as I could
well thank you I believe it's time to
officially dedicate the Ironman
experience so what are we doing here
cutting a ribbon or something that's
better pyro watch this ah
hold on I don't know
ladies and gentlemen the ironman
experience is now officially open
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]